let's dissect what's hurting China's
economy bloated state-owned companies
swelling public and private debt massive
over capacity in the property market and
heavy industry and that is just the
start at an aging population lack of
innovation environmental degradation and
deep-rooted corruption the battle to
contend with these challenges is playing
out in different ways across China's 31
provinces from the rich coastal regions
to the Rust Belt northeast and no one
knows all of this better than Chinese
leaders so here's the situation in 2013
China completed a once in a decade
transfer of power
xi Jinping replaced who Jintao as
president and promised to reform and
rebalance the economy under Xi's
leadership the government abandoned the
one-child policy cracked down on
bribe-taking and sped up steps to make
the currency more tradable but then this
happened the economy ran out of steam
last year growth slowed to 6.9 percent
its weakest pace in a quarter century as
the shift from exports and manufacturing
to services and consumption took its
toll jitters hit the booming stock
market triggering an epic bust that
wiped out 5 trillion dollars of value
and prompted the government to intervene
so what happened to embracing market
forces here's the argument on one side
the IMF and China's trading partners say
the country needs to loosen the guiding
hand of the state if it truly seeks
economic reform and on the face of it
Chinese leaders agree but then they go
and prop up the stock market revealing
an instinct to shelve all of those
reforms when the going gets tough
reining in financial excess and tackling
spiraling debt have become greater
priorities in the quest to protect
growth yet squeezed too hard and the
whole economy could founder